on the third stage of his brief surprise
European tour after trips to London and
Paris president zielinski flew with the
French President Emmanuel macron to
Brussels
in the capital of the European Union he
was again repeating the same message
thanks for all your help but Ukraine
still needs more slavo Cranium he told
the PAC session of the European
Parliament that Ukraine's home in the
future is as part of Europe
we are moving closer to the European
Union Ukraine will be a member of the
European Union Ukraine that is winning
will be a member of a European Union
that is winning
after standing ovations in the
parliament a short drive away he was
again greeted with Applause by the
leaders of all the eu's 27 Nations
when he sat down with them he laid out
his specific requests
we need artillery guns ammunition modern
tanks long-range missiles modern
aircraft at a news conference president
zielinski wouldn't detail the responses
he's received to his wish list but he
said the conversations have been
constructive he also stressed that time
is critical with the new Russian
offensive expected in the coming weeks
James Bay's Al Jazeera Brussels